kubernetes i hear everyone has been
talking about it and you've probably
heard of it too
it's become pretty popular and i think
it's time to learn what it is
with a whole universe of things to learn
it's important to start with the
essentials
let's go over the concepts that make
kubernetes usable scalable and just
downright
awesome are you ready hey caslin good to
see you
i was just going over what kubernetes is
that sounds like fun
kubernetes is a portable extensible open
source platform for managing
containerized workloads and services
that facilitates both declarative
configuration and automation
letting you run distributed systems
resiliently with scaling and failover
for your application
okay well uh that's a lot do you have a
way to simplify that
good call basically it's a container
orchestrator that helps make sure that
each container is where it's supposed to
be
and that the containers can work
together oh yeah that makes me think of
a conductor that manages everything in
an orchestra you know
are the horns going oh the drums they
should be going now
exactly there's a lot of moving points
in a scalable application
just like a conductor makes sure the
song sounds like a composer wants
kubernetes make sure services are
running smoothly the way an app
developer wants
okay before we get into more details
about the what let's go over
why it was created see there are a lot
of applications that we call
monoliths which means they put all the
functionality like transactions third
party integration
into a single deployable artifact and
monoliths are a common way to build
applications even today
but they still have their downfalls for
example deployments can take a long time
since everything has to roll out all
together and if different parts of the
monolith are managed by different teams
there could be a lot of additional
complexity when prepping for a rollout
and scaling has the same problem teams
have to throw resources at the whole
application
even if the bottleneck is only on a
single area
right so people came up with
microservices
each piece of functionality is split
apart into smaller individual artifacts
if there's an update only that exact
service has to be replaced
and the microservice model has scaling
benefits too now individual services can
be scaled to match their traffic so it's
easier to avoid bottlenecks
without over provisioning this is all
great but having one machine
for each service would require a lot of
resources
and a whole bunch of machines that's why
containers are the perfect choice
with containers teams can package up
their services neatly
all the applications their dependencies
and any necessary configuration
get delivered together this also means
that they can be sure their services
will run the same way
no matter where they're run but there's
still more
problems that remain unsolved upgrading
a container is easy since you can create
a new version of the container and
deploy it in place of the old one
but how can upgrades be done without
downtime
how do these containers know how to talk
to the other ones
and how can the app developer debug
issues and observe what's happening
and now we've come back to the conductor
of our container orchestra
kubernetes is all about managing these
containers on virtual machines
or nodes the nodes in the containers
they run are grouped together as a
cluster
and each container has endpoints dns
storage and scalability
everything that modern applications need
without the manual effort of doing it
yourself
kubernetes automates most of the
repetition and inefficiencies of doing
everything by hand
the app developer tells kubernetes what
it wants the cluster to look like
and kubernetes makes it happen see this
all sounds amazing
so everyone should just switch to
kubernetes yeah
well not so fast microservices still
have their own unique
challenges and sometimes a monolith can
be the right solution
based on what's right for the
application itself and monoliths
can still run on kubernetes even though
they won't be able to use all the same
benefits
hmm either way how do you know when
you're ready to get started with
kubernetes
well the first step is to start using
containers that's easier said than done
but let's save that for the next episode
okay
so now we have an idea of what kinds of
problems kubernetes helps with
and we've also got an orbital view of
what it actually does
yep next time let's dig into containers
containers huh okay stay tuned everybody
if you want to get hands on check out
the link in the description and if you
enjoyed the episode
subscribe for more